et dans a été réélu est ce que vous êtes
de ceux qui disent que le plus dur
commence oui oui il n'ya pas de doute
que la séquence qui s'ouvre la nouvelle
ère
le président de la république l'a appelé
dans son discours de remerciement
cette nouvelle ère c'est évidemment le
défi le plus important l'exigence la
plus haute la question est comment
répondre à cette élection on s'imagine
que les 19 millions de français qui ont
voté emmanuel macron les rouges juste
pas dit on continue comme avant quelle
est la réponse qu'il faut apporter
d'abord il faut identifier le problème
les problèmes les plus importants
le problème le plus important pour moi
c'est cette rupture qu'on ressent entre
une grande partie de la population est
généralement ceux qui travaillent ceux
qui ont des revenus plus faibles ceux
qui habitent en province où le sentiment
qu'ils ont que la société française
comme elle est organisée avec ses
pouvoirs avec ses puissants en tout cas
ceux qui font semblant d'être puissant
les médias le monde politique le monde
des intellectuels joue gros guillemets
intellectuelle que tout ce monde là ne
reconnaît pas la société française comme
elle est et les femmes et les hommes et
les familles comme il savait dire que la
priorité c'est d'abord la réconciliation
et trouver un amant un moyen de leur
parler à eux se sentent pas représentés
la réconciliation à la fois civique
président a dit il ya ceux qui ont voté
pour moi et naturellement ils ont une
place où une reconnaissance ceux qui se
sont abstenus qui n'ont pas voulu
choisir et ceux qui ont voté pour son
adversaire marine le pen et tout cela
forme une seule france
ce dont on ne se rend plus compte et
donc les je sais pas si le mot
réconcilier le meilleur les souder
proposer à nouveau à tous ceux qui sont
si divers d'avoir un projet en commun de
le partager et de trouver les méthodes
ça fait longtemps vous que ce projet est
que cette de france là ça fait longtemps
que je le plateau ça fait longtemps que
vous le défendez en est ce que c'est un
message social qui a été envoyée au
président de la république est ce que
c'est un demande d'ordre de fermeté en
gros est ce que c'est une réponse de
droite ou une réponse de gauche qu'il
faut donner aujourd'hui alors je suis le
plus mal placé pour répondre à votre
question parce que depuis le temps que
nous faisons des émissions ensemble j'ai
toujours plaidé que c'était une
absurdité de découper les réponses entre
droite et gauche qu'on avait besoin au
contraire d'une inspiration qui qui
fédère qui rassemble c'est pourquoi j'ai
toujours été à un militant défenseurs de
l'idée d'un centre puissant parce que
c'est là qu'on se concentre trouvait se
réconcilie les gens qui ont fait des
carrières d'un côté et de l'autre et
puis ce qu'ils s'aperçoivent le moment
venu que dans les moments graves ils
sont ensemble un message social social
et civique sociales civiques le l'idée
que nous ne vivons pas dans des mondes
séparés et que de la société
avec ce qu'elle a pour certains de
privilégier pour d'autres efforts et de
difficultés cette société là elle est
une et notre projet français c'est même
la marque spécifique dans l'histoire au
travers des siècles du projet français
c'est cette unité là qui nous permettra
dans les moments exigeant de dépasser
comment les choix d'un événement
vraiment là par exemple alors un exemple
quand sir passe à l'écologie sur
l'écologie
ce qui a été présenté c'est en effet un
défi technique
écologique de d'inventer de nouveaux
modes de déplacement et de polluer moi
en tout cas d' émettre moins de gaz à
effet de serre et si on y réfléchit bien
ça devrait aussi permettre à la société
française d'être de produire en
industrie en agriculture n'ai aucune des
sociétés qui nous entoure et si nous
savons relever ce défi là alors nous
serons devant nous serons un pays qui
sera à la longueur la question c'est
quelles sont les ai déjà bien vous voyez
bien que
c'est une journaliste comme vous d'une
émission comme celle ci tout le monde
envie que ça se passe comme ça alors ça
signifie que quelque chose a bougé dans
le social écologie sur console moore 48
mille victimes sur les émissions de gaz
à effet serre je pense qu'il ya un
consensus en revanche sur la méthode
comment est-ce qu'on avis arrive
justement à faire affaire pays à faire
nation c'est ce que vous expliquez à
l'instant on entend beaucoup parler
d'une nouvelle ère d'une nouvelle
méthode de la concertation et dans le
même temps on entend bruno le maire qui
dit qu'ils excluent pas tu prends le
49-3 pour faire la réforme des retraites
je vais défendre mes positions allez-y
parce que je parle pas à la place des
autres je pense que pendant très
longtemps on a cru que la politique se
résumer au passage en force
y compris au passage en force annoncé
l'autorité je suis venu
dans mon programme il était écrit que
j'allais faire ceci et donc j'ai
désormais la liberté l'autorité la
légitimité vous passer en force moi je
crois que ce temps est derrière nous je
pense que la société enfin tous ceux qui
qui vous écoutent et qui sort et qui
forment la france ceux là ont besoin
d'être
associé convaincu entraîné que on ne
considère pas
qu'il faut au fond dépasser les
oppositions des uns et des autres que ça
n'a aucune importance vous savez la
méthode que madame thatcher utiliser et
qui a fait beaucoup rêver un certain
nombre de responsables politiques ces
méthodes là c'est fini c'est pour moi en
tout temps que ça veut dire ce sont les
méfiances et finit pas du tout c'est
absolument le contraire si vous prenez
le temps de poser le problème en termes
compréhensibles
le problème du langage politique c'est
que la plupart du temps il est
incompréhensible pour pour ceux qui
vivent avec nous
incompréhensible parce qu'il est fait de
statistiques et de mots tellement
spécialisé en tant que personne ne les
comprends et donc si vous prenez le
temps en langage simple en langage de
tous les jours
d'expliquer les problèmes on va avoir à
résoudre les solutions disponibles
de discuter ou de dialoguer avec
l'ensemble des forces du pays et au bout
du compte de trancher ça veut dire que
cette réforme des retraites qui va être
un gros gros sujet du début du
quinquennat ça veut dire qu'il faut pas
se dire que c'est une urgence ça veut
dire qu'il faut dire aux français on va
se laisser le temps de la faire quand
vous serez prêt c'est une urgence mais
c'est pas une urgence en terme de jours
c'est une urgence on peut on peut tout à
fait prendre les quelques mois
nécessaires pour que chacun des français
à sa place ouf on fasse son choix mesure
ce qu'il en est exemple très simple si
on ne fait pas la réforme des retraites
alors il y a deux options ou bien on
augmente les cotisations ça veut dire
qu'on baisse des salaires ou bien on
baisse les pensions ça veut dire qu'on
baisse les retraites est ce que c'est un
choix que les français souhaitent ou
accepte je suis persuadé que non à
condition que tout le monde comprenne
que on va traiter différemment ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler très tôt
qu'ils vont avoir la possibilité de
partir plus tôt qu'on va traiter
différemment tout ce dont les métiers
sont difficiles physiquement difficile
parce que ça casse le dos ça casse les
reins ou bien simplement c c'est
tellement fatigant nerveusement
et que après on va faire de l'incitation
sarah toussaint y arrive
il faut une harmonie une stéréophonie
entre les deux figures de l'exécutif
c'est ce que vous dites ce matin dans le
figaro il faut un clone de macron à
matignon non sur mon jeu sûrement pas
heureusement l'harmonie vous savez bien
ça dans votre famille l'harmonie c'est
pas entre semblables dans l'harmonie
c'est entre des personnalités dont le
la marque de fabrique personnel est
différente mais qui simplement
souhaité ont envie rêve vibre aux mêmes
choses et si on a sept alors c'est à la
fois du respect mutuel et de l'air et
qu'en attendant on vous entend parler on
sait que vous avez ça avec emmanuel
macron pourquoi ce serait pas le moment
aujourd'hui
pour vous d'aller à matignon je ne parle
jamais de ses sujets à la première
personne parce que vous voyez bien que
sa fausse complètement le jugement si
celui que vous interrogez vient est en
fait si leur nom à dire je suis prêt
c'est pour lui qu'ils qu'il qu'il parle
ça fausse complètement la discussion par
exemple ségolène royal lui pose la
question est ici la question n'a été
posée je réfléchirai et bien si j'étais
ségolène royal de leçon ça n'aurait pas
échappé vous avez raison la république
en marche le modem horizon les arrivants
de gauche les futurs entrants de droite
à quoi doit rassembler la majorité c'est
très simple il ya deux ans je je dis pas
qu'ils sont si faciles que ça parce que
rien n'est facile dans la vie comme vous
savez il ya deux ans je le premier c'est
l'unité
on ne peut pas se lancer dans une
période aussi difficile que celle là
avec des gens qui travaillent agissent
en fait les uns contre les autres pour
eux pour leurs propres objectifs et la
deuxième chose c'est le respect de la
diversité des différences va quand même
pas tous pareils on pense pas tous de la
même manière j'ai déjà dit ça dans trois
fois dans l'histoire on pense pas tous
de la même manière mais on peut
travailler et agir et réfléchir ensemble
merci beaucoup france amer d'avoir été
mon invité ce matin